hey guys and welcome back to the layah heilpern
show powered by icon plus so really quickly for
you so icon recently launched bridge a direct
fiat on and off ramp service for all icon dats
so newcomers can now bank on icon without even
knowing that they are using blockchain so very
cool for the icon now like that now i want to
say thank you to my sponsors block fight i use
them to earn up to 8.6 interest on my usdc so
that is incredibly exciting you can also get 250
when you sign up um so i'm going to leave the link
for you somewhere and everywhere and a last quick
shout out before i bring on my guests to coinflip
so you can actually get 10 off their transactions
i'm gonna leave a discount code running for you
in a minute now if you are watching on youtube
please don't forget to hit the like button and
subscribe so you never miss any of these fantastic
guests now today is a pretty interesting guest i'm
very excited to bring him on he is a um podcaster
he's a youtuber it is of course btc sessions also
known as ben what's up ben hey i'm i'm great i'm
super excited to be here and there's just so
much going on so i i can't wait to chat yeah
i'm super excited i think we're really lucky to be
going live right now because of what is going on
now let's just jump straight into it i want to
give the audience the juice the chocolate the cake
straight away i don't see any reason to hold
back so gamestop right that is what's kind of
taken the world by storm not just the original
um traditional financial markets but it's taking
the crypto world by storm so for those that don't
know i think back in march in 2020 it was trading
at around 3.25 now this week i'm not sure what
the price is right this second but i think it
hit above 150 so gamestop is something is one of
those companies which have just been unfortunately
declining so tell us why is it going up explain
what is happening well okay so one of the things
that has happened here is i mean gamestop yes i i
will grant that the model it's it's maybe a model
that's on its way out right like the physical
locations where you go to pick up physical games
things are going very much digital um that said
people still go there um i've still gone there
from time to time and still utilize it but but
these guys have been uh effectively shorted
by a lot of these hedge funds um saying that the
stock is going to crater but it's the amount that
they've been shorting this stock betting that the
stock will go down that is of particular interest
so they were able to short this stock for and
forty percent which means forty percent more than
the total outstanding shares they were able to
take the opposite side of that bet so what ended
up happening is a group of people on reddit known
as wall street bets saw this as an opportunity and
they said well hey you know these guys typically
get to set the rules and they get to do whatever
the hell they want whenever the hell they want to
do it and there's always just no repercussions for
these guys they if they screw up bad enough they
will get bailed out by the banks um and so what
they said is let's just go buy up buy the hell
out of gamestop and pump it through the roof and
actually that price point i've seen much higher
i've seen it over 300 i think at one point it was
over 400 like it's it's insane um so everybody
went in and they were just pumping the hell out
of the stock and these hedge funds were losing
billions of dollars and so what ended up happening
uh is some of the investors in uh robin hood
app where a lot of people are buying this stock
are also in in bed with the hedge funds that
were shorting uh we're shorting gamestop
uh so robin hood has removed uh gamestop as an
option to trade so what you can do is if you
own gamestop you can sell it but you cannot buy
more so they've given a one-way street to retail
investors while hedge funds can strategically uh
mitigate the risk and re-allocate so that they're
they're safe which never never happens
if somebody in retail is losing money oh
no the the little guy's losing money don't
worry we'll stop the market so you guys can
can get out okay that has never happened ever and
was the last time you saw this uh the trading of
any asset shut down because it was going up too
much never until the big guys are losing the money
i love everything that is happening here
because there's this growing swell of kind of
screw the elites at the top that that don't get to
play by the rules they get to privatize the gains
and they get to socialize the losses by getting
bailouts which are paid for by taxpayers or paid
for by inflation which is a hidden tax on regular
citizens so you know what this lines up perfectly
with the ethos of bitcoin and what i'm interested
in and more power to them i think that these guys
they've got the right mindset i think
that they're they're poking the bear there
they're definitely stirring stirring stuff up um
but i i think what we're seeing now with everybody
effectively being shut out of buying this because
it's uh stepped on the wrong toes is that the
whole thing is is effectively rigged for the big
boys at the top um and the little guys don't have
much of a chance if they play in their playground
what i'm waiting for is for these guys to start
to recognize the the underlying problem because
right now they're attacking kind of the symptoms
and i i guess we can look back to say 2008 in
the financial crisis right you had a bunch of
people playing with other monies other people's
money making very very risky bets and they were
doing this because they didn't think they would
get burned but then when they did get burned
there was actually zero consequence because we
spun up the money printers and we funneled all
that new money back to make them whole again
and everybody else got left footing the bill
the reason that was possible is because the
underlying currency itself can do that you
have the function of being able to turn on those
monty money printers and allocate capital where
you know the people at the top see fit and when
you get down to it we're seeing this play out it's
shining a spotlight on the actual problem right
now these guys are attacking kind of the symptoms
of the underlying problem but bitcoin is very much
born from that same ethos of there's something
systemically wrong and we can't fix the system we
can just create a better one that's why we're here
yeah i think well firstly you explain that
beautifully so absolutely well done i thought that
was explained really really well i think you know
especially so firstly there are two things going
on here i think you have um obviously what's going
on in reddit you have the group sort of pumping up
the the price of it but then you have what we've
seen today robin hood actually sort of jumping
in right and i think this is going to be the most
insane thing for the space because it really shows
the need for decentralization and you have a lot
of young people right on apps like tick tock so on
tick tock you literally have people talking about
different stocks um you know there's a whole niche
and for generation z like not just millennials but
generation z wanting to get into the stock market
because i think that they are sort of switched
on that the game is rage you know we don't really
want the nine to five there must be a better way
you know we've seen those videos coming onto um
onto twitter people sort of saying like you know
look what the big guys are doing we've got to do
better you know we're seeing them sort of talking
about these things but we're not seeing them make
that jump into crypto because crypto still sort of
seen as this um let's just say i don't know this
dark uh criminal sort of community or whatever it
is um but wow the whole the whole deep like you
know it goes into like the whole deep platforming
it goes into the whole banning and it really just
makes the case for cryptocurrency i think um
you know this is why we need decentralized
applications this is why we need somebody
that just isn't in charge you know once no one
single point of failure no one single centralized
authority um do you think that this is going to be
a real opportunity for these kind of people this
kind of market to move into crypto i think it's
going to take time i think um yeah i i think that
you'll see some people start to get it but it's
it's a journey right like these these people
they they managed to find a [ __ ] in the armor
of of the guys at the top but in in doing so
these guys have effectively said you're out
you know if you do something we don't
like we will just stop it in its tracks
and so the connection is there to be made
and i see some people on twitter already
making that connection obviously with a bunch
of bitcoiners behind them saying hey you know
poking and prodding but i mean yeah it's amazing
good for these guys screw the guys at the top
i let it burn i'd honestly let it burn um
and the other beautiful thing about this is
uh there's not a lot that the left and
the right can agree on but you know what
i've seen and i tend to in terms of especially
like monetary policy and like the how to fix
some of the problems in our in our system i tend
to lean a little right on that but i've seen that
some opposite ends of the spectrum you have like
aoc and like robert reich who was a an advisor
to clinton coming out and calling out the same
bs saying how can robin hood shut down regular
people from buying a stock while the hedge funds
are allowed to trade it like nothing has happened
and and mitigate all their risk while everybody
else gets put out it's just there's a double
standard here and both sides of the spectrum see
it it's just how they approach uh dealing with it
you know i i think on the left it leans towards
more regulations which i think can be loopholed
eventually as they have been and i on the right
it tends to lean towards deregulation um which
can hurt in the short term because scammers can
get in there but um in my opinion i think the
only way around this is becoming anti-fragile as
a system and as an individual because if you get
burned you're going to learn from that and
you're not going to make that mistake again
so yeah i think that's such a cool um observation
and that the left and the right sort of agree on
it because i think you know at the end of the day
i often find when it comes to politics um we all
sort of want the same goal we just have different
ways of getting there and at the end of the day um
so i'm the same as you i fiscally tend to be far
more conservative and on the right um but we all
sort of want a let's call it a level playing field
we all want fairness we all you know especially
the left that's sort of what their foundations
are right um and to think that the little man is
absolutely getting screwed is quite unbelievable
um and insane so you mentioned something earlier
which i just want to kind of um i guess echo
and point out a little bit more so robin hood
banning the the trading of this so you said they
were in bed with with people on wall street what's
the connection there so did this come from wall
street or did it come from robin hood what's the
connection yeah so one of the major i i i just
saw it it was um on an article it was one of the
little disclaimers underneath it uh but uh i can't
remember which i think it was um what's the name
of the hedge fund that was getting capital yeah
yeah uh uh melvin or sorry melvin yeah yeah melvin
so so they are they have money that they've
funneled into robin hood they helped with and
and have funded robin hood itself so of course
like given that they have money in the game of
robin hood or rather that robin hood uh at least
has some influence from melvin capital of course
that's going to be the influence that comes down
there isn't that even like illegal though like
how can you i'm just i'm just sort of thinking
like i'm just trying to i kind of get my words
out okay sorry i will get my words out so how is
that even how is that even legal right like it's
supposed to be a fair trading platform so how can
one of the biggest um i don't know if they're the
biggest but how can such a huge company have such
an investment in a platform it literally means the
game is rigged like how can you do that that is
it's not insider trading but it's a little bit
like insider trading in some way do you see what
i mean yeah well i mean the the answer to this i
suppose would just be more complete transparency
on on what everybody does and you know we don't
typically get that and also complete and free
access uh to anybody for all of those tools
if you have transparency and access for everyone
then you can't screw somebody else uh with an
unfair advantage and yeah so we're just kind
of we're at this place where there's a set of
rules for a certain group of people and there's a
set of rules for another group of people and the
spotlight has been shown on it and i'm sure this
isn't the first or the last that we're going to
be hearing about this and i think the fallout from
this whatever that snowball's into um it's going
to be felt for some time and there's going to be
a lot of questions about this moving forward yeah
absolutely especially if it's something that the
left and right can agree on i mean i know aoc has
a huge amount of influence so um this this should
be fun i'm excited um but let's go let's talk a
little bit more about you so you know everything
um in crypto is very much american-centric i
think most my audience are based in america
um you know sec everything's america right um
nothing else matters but you're canadian so yes um
and i can really hear it in your accent it's fine
i can hear the oh and the the about i can hear it
um so let like teach me a little bit about what
it's like in canada um you know what what's it
like in terms of its approach to cryptocurrencies
yeah so i mean for the most part it's relatively
friendly in terms of a regulatory environment
so um most of now i will say it's a little bit
tighter than than typical uh money transmitting
laws but the laws here are uh anything above a
thousand dollars requires an id um normally for
cash like transactions that is three thousand
so we're a little bit below that not ideal but
better than you know the worst of the worst and
then anything above ten thousand dollars which is
across the board for any type of asset is uh the
anti-money laundering laws come into effect so
you need um more id and proof of proof of where
the funds came from things like that so across
the board there it's it's relatively friendly like
it's not not too cumbersome here it's pretty open
so that's all good now in terms of the government
itself and how it operates and the thing like how
we operate our money um i would say canada is
kind of a shining beacon for why bitcoin exists
uh in in our in our monetary policies i mean don't
get me wrong the us takes the cake because holy
crap but pretty much so right now for example
um the bank of canada and keep in mind that the
size of canada we're like 30 million plus people
so we're like the size of california in terms of
actual people living here um so but uh right
now the bank of canada has stated that it will
effectively print or introduce liquidity into
the market at a wrinkle yeah exactly at least
four billion dollars per week uh so
which is for how long sorry for how long
for as long as it takes they said until uh the
market is stable and inflation targets are met
have you done a calculation of how much that is
a year or uh i i would have to nab can max okay
yeah yeah yeah it's it's plenty and um our
our national debt clock so there's there's
a an advocacy group that keeps track of the
national debt and they had a clock ticker um well
it broke because they ran out of digits recently
they have to add an extra digit because we passed
yeah we passed the one trillion dollar mark which
again compared to the us um is is small but for a
relative 30 million people yeah that's all
relative um our public and private debt
versus the gross domestic product of
the entire country is at 387 percent so
the amount of productivity in the entire country
there is uh 387 percent of that worth of debt
in the country which is insane and just to put it
in perspective this is higher than the greek debt
crisis and it's higher than the peak of the uh the
housing um and the housing bubble in the states
um in terms of debt to gdp ratio we're higher
than both of those so we're on this crash
course and beyond that um we are the only g7
nation that has zero gold reserves like like
zip in fact yeah out of the g7 nations uh
were the only one to have less than 100 tons
of gold as a as a reserve we got rid of it as of
2016 the last of our gold is gone we sold it all
oh wow yeah it's it's unbelievable so like
we're in this really precarious spot where
there's so much debt there's nothing to back it
up and we're not slowing down i mean the us is
is similar but being a world reserve currency they
probably got a little bit more of a runway before
they fly off that cliff um we're probably a little
bit closer to that so i look at those numbers and
they scare the hell out of me uh but again this
is why something like bitcoin exists because if
you're if you're holding dollars if you're holding
canadian dollars yeah yeah like why why would you
want to hold those fiat debt coupons right you you
you want to have like a sound money um and for me
i i live on bitcoin now i i hold as few dollars as
possible so are you would you say you're entirely
unbanked or not you're you hold a few dollars
to pay your bills and so on yeah so do i have
a bank account yes uh i hold as few dollars as
possible i get paid almost exclusively in bitcoin
if somebody wants to pay me in dollars i charge
a premium and then i utilize various uh ramps
in order to like all use here in canada there's a
couple options like bull bitcoin or bitcoin well
and both of those allow you to pay any bill or
fund any bank account using bitcoin and so i
calculate my bills at the beginning of the month
i say okay this is coming out of this account
and as soon as i get paid i'll swap it over
so it's sitting there and the rest that's in
savings is outside of the dollar like i i don't
use it and then i use things like bit refill
or coin cards or whatever to get day-to-day
expenses and so yeah am i jumping through
hoops absolutely but at the end of the day i'm not
holding dollars and i'm better off because of it
yeah i'm with you so how do you um just deal with
taxes then so if you get paid in bitcoin do you
then have to transfer it to dollars so that you
can then calculate it and then transfer it back
to bitcoin i ask because that's something
i'm personally trying to figure out myself
yeah so i mean first off i'm not an
accountant so uh uh i have an accountant uh
no financial advice yeah you're
good yeah disclaimer's done
yeah so so effectively you have to worry about two
different types of taxes in in that instance so
there's there's income tax right so whatever you
got paid the dollar equivalent at that moment you
should account for that and you should probably
convert that and have it sit there for tax time
okay so then that's all dealt with and you have
your your bitcoin that you is actually spendable
that you is your take-home pay your your net um
whatever you save of that and whatever you don't
spend immediately on bills or convert immediately
for bills um if that goes up in value then you
also have to consider capital gains tax so in
canada currently whatever you make let's say i
saved a thousand dollars worth of bitcoin and it
turned into two thousand dollars worth of bitcoin
i made an extra thousand dollars and in canada 50
of that is taxable that doesn't mean they stealed
50 of it it means that half of that so 500 of
the thousand that i made is now considered as
income and then goes into like my yearly income
and that gets taxed at whatever my tax rate is
so just so i understand you pay 50 on capital
gains tax no so did i misunderstand that no so
so um it's kind of like saying that part of your
income they can only apply taxes to half of it
so they're not gonna take the total amount it's
kind of like instead of saying i made a thousand
dollars i only you know to the government they're
saying well you 500 of that you keep tax-free and
the other 500 of it if your tax rate is like 25
will tax 25 of the other half oh sorry so they
so okay so they take fifty percent and then
they tax that fifty percent yeah all right
okay fine yeah yeah so so you know at the end of
the day you know taxes suck right nobody likes
taxes they suck but if people do i gotta just put
that out there i've seen on twitter but anyway
i suppose so yeah but at the end of the
day i'm when i'm looking at it i'm like
am i if i'm paying a capital gains tax that
means i've i've got there's two routes i could
have gone i could have saved my dollars and
they could have been depreciated from beneath
me and i could have gotten effectively nothing
for that or i could have saved my bitcoin if
i need if i when i decide to convert it or spend
it there is a gain on that and then i'm paying
tax on that but just by the fact that i'm paying
tax it means i'm already better off than i was
had i just held the dollars oh i'm i'm absolutely
with you i think you're absolutely jumping through
through hoops but it's worth it um instead
of having your money just sitting there and
losing value and the thing is like we don't we
don't talk about that hidden tax at all we don't
talk about it um and i think it's the most to know
when you go into crypto um especially for someone
at my age because i'm in my 20s so cryptocurrency
really is the first time i sort of went
into crypto and then i understood finance right
so it was the other way around just because of
just because of just because of my age and so on
so it's just so fascinating because nobody talks
to you about inflation nobody sort of says to you
okay you know you can work for nine to five and
just because you save and just because you're not
greedy and you're good doesn't mean that you're
going to be rich at the end of the day um you know
i and i know this might sound ridiculous but for
me i just think it says it all but some people
will sort of say you know that's inflation but
my grandfather bought his house back in 1950s
for three thousand pounds um i yeah i just
and now i think it's worth i don't know like he
doesn't like the north of england so i don't know
maybe it's worth like three hundred thousand
pounds or something like that um it blows my
mind but nobody talks about it yeah it was crazy
because i mean you you see it in some basic items
but it's you see a lot of inflation in assets
things like housing things like stocks like the
stock market rally is not at so much of a rally
as it is assets that shelter you from inflation
inflating themselves right so it's it's kind
of when new money money gets created you've got
to look at where that money flows to if it just
flowed out equally to everybody then it would kind
of be like a zero-sum game because your percentage
of the pie money is just kind of meant to measure
all of the goods and services in an economy if
everybody's percentage of the pie remained the
same but everybody just like added a zero to how
many dollars you have you're no worse or no better
than you were before it doesn't matter but it's
because money gets printed and then funneled to
certain people that that wealth gap keeps growing
and you see you know things like assets where
your grandfather was able to use three thousand
pounds which you know obviously takes a while
to to save up but you you could have done it um
uh he was able to purchase that house and now
people lock in for 30-year mortgages to
do the same thing um so it's it's really
it's very we're fueled by debt to attain the same
standard of living that people used to have and
just because we're kind of you know technology has
moved quicker so we have all these cool gadgets
and everything and uh you know we we have nice
homes and things like that if you can afford one
but to attain that same level every year it's
harder and harder to do so and the inflation
that gets told to us those levels are far from
the truth like in canada here there was statscan
did a study and they said oh inflation's
only been 0.5 percent for the past few years
which is total trash because when they
count inflation they don't include food
they don't include fuel or homes like housing all
of those important things that you kind of really
need day to day they don't count those things
so if you actually want to know what inflation
is at or get a better picture of it there's a
really good website called the chapwood index and
this actually breaks it down city by city i think
just in the u.s but it takes the top 500 items
that the average person in that locale purchases
day to day and it adds up the inflation of those
over the calendar year so if you want to see
what actually people are spending and the
real inflation that they experience just to
maintain their standard of living it's closer to
12 a year it's crazy and that's not even including
like assets like like stocks and stuff like that
and i think you know even a number like that
i just don't think it would be enough to wake
people up because at the end of the day if you're
not taught something you're just not gonna know it
and that is why i personally feel so privileged
to have fallen into this space because i actually
didn't initially choose to be here um
and then and then i decided to stay um
so i i just i i think i'm so i just feel so
privileged honestly to to be here and to be
aware of these things because like we said it's
that hidden tax and you know just because you save
it it really doesn't mean anything but speaking
of bitcoin i feel like we've got to talk about
it we've got to talk about the market so gosh
we've got it's been a bit of a ride hasn't it
so we passed the all-time high and then we did
all-time high after all-time high and then we
hit 42k that was fab and then we retraced what
was it like 28 some people are expecting 27k
so just give us your thoughts yeah well i mean
if we look historically at kind of what happened
last time around in the bull run 2017 it's pretty
par for the course um in fact we've been shy of
the pullbacks that we've seen previously so
through the whole bull run of 2017 there were
seven pullbacks in and around in some cases up to
like 38 around 40 somewhere in that realm happened
seven times over uh we haven't hit that i think
hitting that would have been closer to 25 or 26k
in that realm would have been that pullback maybe
that happens maybe it doesn't i'm not sure but
even still if we were to drop to 26k in a few days
i wouldn't be particularly worried about it um
the other thing to think about is if if you
think that history will rhyme then you got
to look at the lengths of those pullbacks
too and some of them were as long as 55 days
uh you know some of them were kind of like i'd
say between 40 and 55 days was kind of the average
and so far it's been about 20. so we're kind
of like smack dab in the middle of that if
history rhymes then within a few weeks we might
see us right back up there at 42 and then blowing
through it so time will tell if this feels
very familiar to me it feels like a rehash
um but i i'm i'm not freaking out
about this at all i've just been
sitting back and really enjoying yeah yeah
literally i think um yeah i mean it's pretty it's
been pretty insane because people aren't really
sure which kind of market we're in right i think
you and i are like bull market and then i think
it was cnn that put out the headline that was uh
28 crash now we're in an hour in a bear market um
i mean you know bitcoin sort of moving sideways
so how long does it need to move sideways for
until we sort of determine there's a bear market
if we don't get that you know corrupt
correction and we just guess it's really
corrected but it doesn't go back up to
uh yeah well first off cnbc or cnn is cnn
yeah okay so they're measuring they're measuring
bear market by by the traditional definition of
it which is a 20 drop okay if that's their
measurement then we had seven bear markets
during 2017. so you know take that that as with
a grain of salt um you know if if we sat at
kind of this level if we traded sideways for
like four months or something i'd be like uh
it's definitely different maybe maybe things take
longer now maybe it's it's not going to be those
kind of quick ups and downs i'm doubtful i you
know some i've seen some people saying how this
time it's going to be different we've got you know
institutional interests different kinds of money
coming in and so there's you know we're not going
to see that eventual bear market hmm i don't know
companies are still run by people i think we're
still going to see the crazy volatility i think
we're still going to see the kind of run that
we saw in 2017 i don't know to what extent but
you know the calls of like multiple hundreds
of thousands of dollars from a lot of different
institutions and individuals i don't think
those are unreasonable whatsoever i would not
be surprised to see him i'd be very excited it's
one thing talking about it versus experiencing it
um but what if we were to get to those levels
yeah absolutely i could easily see us seeing like
another 60 70 80 bear market um that dragged on
for another couple of years but then if we survive
that then next time instead of institutions it's
nation states right like it i think i think we're
just it repeats it repeats it repeats it's like
watching groundhog day with bill murray where
he wakes up and it's the same day every day
uh yeah it's that it's that but it's for your
bitcoin epochs yeah no i'm with you um yeah i i
think i think it's i think it's exciting i think
um i think it was samson mao that said um you know
on the run up to 100k we're gonna get these 20 30
pullbacks um when things were running back in i
said back in january earlier earlier in january um
people were 100k this year 100 q1 2021 you
know sort of predicting it at the end of q1
let's say like march i'm not gonna ask for a price
prediction um but give one if you feel um but do
you think that 100k is even likely this year i
mean i think 100k is likely in the grand scheme
of life um but in the grand scheme of 2021
is it how um how likely do you think it is
if somebody's top target is 100k
this year i think they're bearish
like that's that's my sentiment like that's
again and i could be wrong like it could be
like people say and it's gonna be more drawn
out but yeah i don't i don't think so everything
seems to be very similar to 2017 and like we're
barely we're like 50 above the all-time high at
one point we had doubled the all-time high
in 2017 we went from 1k to 20 in the course
of a calendar year we did it basically if you
actually look at like the all-time high it was
around 1200 so we did like a 17 x or something
like that easily in in 2017 the difference now
is that you have institutions actually draining
liquidity from exchanges and actually keeping
it on their books which means if retail fomo
hits then how how do exchanges handle that it's
like you there just won't be enough so could
we see a mania to multiple hundred thousands
yeah like if the conditions are right you know
what happens when there's a wall street bet
sentiment on shorting the dollar and buying
bitcoin i'm so ready for that i'm ready for that
me too because someone there because don't just
put a request into reddit for me but i like i like
that you're bullish i need to let my brother know
actually because he brought in at 40k bless him um
so but he's good he's calm he's chill he's smart
he knows he's in it for the long run so it's chill
um so let's talk about institutions and jumping
into bitcoin because i think that has what has
made everything very different this time around
um michael stella has obviously sort of taken
the lead with that but an interesting
thing that i want to talk about is how
important is that do you think for the price so
what happens um if michael sailor turns around
and says you know i've made enough i bought in the
average price i brought in bought in was at let's
say 15 16 17k the average price um any leaves i
don't think he will but what happens if he leaves
are we are we sort of resting on institutions
um i mean yeah well people with a lot of money
can afford to move the price currently right
that you know if if somebody's moving you know
he was he was able to strategically position
himself in the market without moving it too much
um you know and so i think we're still kind of at
that stage but liquidity is indeed drying up now
what turn what happens when one's institution
turns around and dumps well one already did
um because of the flood and maybe we'll
get that to that later but there you know
there's a double spin flat article and one of the
companies that bought um that bought some bitcoin
i think they bought like 100 and something bitcoin
and then they dumped it um are we immune to that
kind of stuff no obviously not again companies
are run by people and people can do stupid things
sometimes um what happens if michael saylor turns
around and sells well he sells it to somebody who
wants it more than him uh so you know do you do
you know if michael saylor is selling his bitcoin
and all the bitcoiners are buying it back up
well are they going to give it up later like
whose hands who are they transferring bitcoin
to right now you have people that sold 40k
um and you have guggenheim which was projecting
400 000 bitcoin that isn't allowed to buy until
the end of january saying well we hit 35k which
was a technical turnaround point so maybe time
to take some money off the table screw you
guys you guys can't buy yet you said 400k
you're just wanting the market to dip so that
you can buy some cheap corn like that's well
didn't they predict they were the ones
that predicted 20k the other day now
yeah yeah yeah they predicted
20k the other day and i'm like
you i'm like i did a video about it on top i
was like come on like you everybody knows you
want to buy bitcoin and now you're predicting 20k
yeah they know you want to buy and they know you
can't buy yet what like show me the incentives
and i'll show you the outcome this is exactly
what you would expect from somebody like that that
is waiting to buy in the sidelines and can't yet
they're gonna say some stuff to maybe kind of
wink wink nudge nudge like yeah it's let's slap
i said it but i didn't say it kind of thing yeah
um okay so you mentioned the fun that's something
i also want to talk to you about so for those
that missed it give us the lowdown what happened
okay so uh bit max research noticed something
funky on the blockchain where there appeared to be
uh coins that were spent in two places at
once and somebody kind of caught on to this
and the headline was effectively bitcoin may
be broken because somebody was able to spend
their money twice this is not correct and so
let me just kind of give give you an idea of
what actually happened so so bitcoin itself is
kind of all about obtaining consensus on who
owns what and that can take different amounts of
time typically within a single block or 10 minutes
you get an updated state of the ledger of who
owns what okay and you can be fairly certain
that that's how it's gonna be and that moving
forward as more blocks of transactions are added
to that it it becomes very difficult to change
that on occasion two miners at the same time will
mine a block of transactions so there may be
slightly different transactions in one than the
other and at this point you're never quite sure
which transactions are going to be officially
added to the bitcoin blockchain in what order and
so it takes until the next block of transactions
is mined where you can be reasonably sure okay
well this is going to be the chain moving forward
that happened but in that happening somebody
also used a feature of bitcoin called rbf or
replace by fee and this allows you to broadcast a
transaction and if you decide that it's one it's
taking too long you can add a bigger fee or if
you'd like to change where those funds are going
you can actually add a higher fee in the hopes
that that transaction will get picked up instead
so somebody was sending money to a wallet they
changed their mind about the amount and where
they wanted that money to go so they used
rbf or replace by fee to broadcast another
version of that transaction that went somewhere
somewhere else at the same time they did that
both transactions were mined separately in
those separate blocks so there was a period
in time where we weren't sure which one was going
to be official and as soon as the next block was
mined it was official that this was the winning
transaction and that one was no longer valid
so just a quick question i'm just going to jump in
so when you say you know one one transaction here
one transaction so it was the same coin asking
for a different thing yeah it was it was hey i
originally wanted to send my coins here and i
broadcast that and it was mined but then i also
had broadcast an alternative transaction and that
one was mined separately at the same time and so
for a moment in time we weren't sure which
one was going to be the official transaction
it turns out that the lower fee one actually
won funny enough but anyways as soon as that
next block was mined the old transaction was no
longer valid and was gone and so this is actually
just how bitcoin works it's all just waiting
until you can be sure of where the funds are
it's all about the consensus of who owns what
so the people that were freaking out about it
just didn't understand how bitcoin worked and
it was literally a function of the network
okay that's pretty interesting um so at the end so
yeah at the end of it really it's all about what
was confirmed and only one was confirmed yeah yeah
exactly yeah so so now there's uh it's called an
orphan block so that's what it was they were they
were valid transactions at the time but based on
where the chain went they're no longer that block
is no longer valid it just kind of sits there
and is not included in the bitcoin blockchain
okay so speaking of fud um there's also been
some tether fud um could you clear that one up
for us because i think you are very eloquent in
the way that you uh explain these confusing things
so let's get on to tether yeah so tether i mean
it's such a rehash of everything we're in the 20s
this is why i think that it's going to be the same
as 2017 because even the fud is just like
repeating it's on repeat well tether you know
there's always been rumors that effectively tether
is a stable coin that is printed from nothing to
specifically to pump the price of bitcoin that's
that's kind of the general thesis behind it
um for a long time there were rumors that tether
was not back one to one by dollars they refuted
that claim eventually they actually did move to
a model where they say they can have dollars or
equivalent value assets and so i mean the number
one question is tether backed one to one by
dollars or equivalent i mean i don't know for sure
i have no idea but let's kind of reel it back and
look at the implications of what people are saying
tether designed specifically to pump bitcoin
and you know that's that's why it's created there
so if that's the case why did they stop in 2018
2019 and only restart in 2020 like that's
that's the first question like why stop if
it was working why stop because tether has been
around for a while um the other principle that i
want to touch on is just because let's say let's
say that all the rumors are true let's say tether
effectively had nothing and we're printing fake
dollars i mean one that's already happening with
the real dollars so but let's let's try let's
draw a comparison to let's say dollars in gold
because they've printed so many dollars over
since we went off the gold standard in 71
does that make gold any less valuable now at
the time when we went off the gold standard
it was 35 dollars were worth uh one gold one
ounce of gold now it's around two thousand
because we've printed so much money you know is is
gold less valuable because more dollars exist to
represent it in my opinion it's kind of you found
a sly way to get somebody to hand over a valuable
asset in exchange for a non-valuable asset um
but i very much doubt that tether single-handedly
drives the price of bitcoin because if that
was the game they would at one point have to
exchange that bitcoin for dollars if that's
what their game plan was uh i i just don't
see it okay you know i i it not all of it adds
up to me it seems like it's just garbage food
yeah no no i i get that and i think a lot of this
stuff has already been um dispelled in the last
few weeks um but you know it's good to go over so
speaking of um fudd and i guess people that don't
like bitcoin um let's bring up our best friend
peter schiff so so someone like peter schiff
what is going on you know because he's
kind of making okay of course he's made
a name for himself because of gold like i'm
not gonna um i'm not gonna dispute that but
he's also making a name for himself for being
this anti-bitcoin person um somebody who says you
can't buy anything with bitcoin and then lets you
buy things on his website using cryptocurrencies
which is fun so do you even where does this hate
come from um a part of me phil's i think he owns
bitcoin what do you think i i don't i don't
think he owns bitcoin to be honest uh his son
does his son yeah his son does i love that is his
so spencer his son definitely does and i love that
so you know i i always say whenever i'm talking
about peter schiff and his son i say you know
short shift gold and long shift sats because i
want his son to create a company called shift sats
i think that would be poetic but besides the fact
you know peter schiff is he's just entrenched
right like his whole life has been dedicated to
a lot of the fundamental reasoning why that drive
bitcoiners and why we believe in bitcoin but he
can't fathom the idea that something has come
along and done what gold does but better and has
corrected the the weaknesses in gold that led to
the abolition of the gold standard right it was
it was physical it was easily centralized and it
wasn't easily divisible so we had to abstract away
via paper notes and that led to people creating
more paper notes than gold bitcoin you don't have
that problem because it's just so divisible and
even when you get down to a single sat level you
jump to lightning network and you can divide those
so you know it's it it does away with that
inherent centralization now do people leave
bitcoin on exchanges absolutely but easily
auditable as well so like if you have a bunch
of funds that buy a bitcoin and they all claim to
have you know x amount of bitcoin you start doing
the math and it adds up to 30 million bitcoin you
know something's up and you might want to pull out
your money very quickly so yeah like i i he's just
a perma bear and it's because of his entrenched
interest i actually i framed a tweet of his
hold on no he did oh my god i framed it in gold
so this he tweeted this on january 6th of 2020
and he said for those bitcoin bugs excited about
bitcoin's 4 rally in 2020 think about this gold
is also up by about the same percentage this year
only with significantly less downside risk if this
is the best rally bitcoin can muster how will it
ever hit 50k let alone 1 million and this thing
is aging like like milk like it's it's hilarious
how bad of a call this what like four percent
up we were like seven or eight k when he tweeted
wait well what date was that this was january 6
of 2020. oh i thought you said 2021 yeah that was
beautiful my brother wow this has been sitting
on my shelf for a year and it's gonna sit there
for many more wait you need you need to like
have you told him or am i does he know oh
yeah i tweet i tweet him all the time i take
like pictures of me on my pillow snuggling it
it's great i love it i love the i love the cool
for um 50k that's brilliant because one year
later we were just 8 000 away yeah my guess
my guess is that that that tweet part of it
the first call is obliterated this year and then
within five years the second call is obliterated
that's wild i freaking love that that's so funny
um but speaking of all of all this stuff then
it'll be really cool to hear um your thoughts on
bitcoin's place um in i always feel like saying
the world to come that sounds really weird um it
sounds like some religious way of saying it but
in the next few decades where do you see bitcoin
you know you mentioned the lightning network but
people will often say bitcoin can't scale the
lightning now because a failed um project and so
on so it's a store of value is it a global reserve
currency is it a day-to-day payments um solution
what is bitcoin these days or what's it
going to be eventually all of those things um
yeah but i think you've got to have priorities
and you've got to protect the the base layer
so that it can become all of those things
and that means that baseline transactions may
at times be expensive so again i've already kind
of alluded to it in the show but i live on bitcoin
so and people say that it's unusable and you can't
use it day to day i literally do it every day so
you're wrong um but besides you're wrong
um so you know like what am i interested in
first and foremost well i want sound money i want
a separation of money and state i want censorship
resistance i want immutability of the actual
underlying code so that i know the rules governing
it that say it's limited can't be screwed with
and can't be easily changed um you know i want
it's secured via you know a consensus algorithm
that is not easily gamed so for me the only viable
option for that is proof of work because it's
prohibitively expensive to attack the network and
then i want it to be easily verifiable via my own
node which i'm running a bitcoin node right behind
me and all of my wallets connect to that and i
also want it to be leaderless like i don't want
to see the ceo plastered i don't want to see the
the creator placer somewhere i don't want them
to be able to influence the market because in
a lot of instances when there's a figurehead or
there's a foundation when they say jump everybody
holding it says how high and so they get in these
kind of deity-like positions where they can
influence it even if they don't intend to so
i want all of those things and when i take
that litmus test and i test it against anything
outside of bitcoin i don't see it it's it
doesn't tick all of those boxes for me and
so that's why i'm centered around bitcoin yeah
i get that i think um i think it's interesting
a lot of bitcoins do say they they see bitcoin
becoming everything um i definitely wholeheartedly
see bitcoin as gold 2.0 as that store of value um
as that way to opt out um i i'm not saying no but
i for me i'm yet to sort of be fully convinced
and i'm really excited to see if bitcoin really
could be the global reserve currency if it really
could be um that day-to-day payment solution and
because if so then that's that's amazing you know
if we could be like paying taxes and bitcoin and
just keeping everything in bitcoin um because
right now like you said jumping through hoops
it is a lot so ideally that's what i would also
like i just i'm not 100 but i'm so excited i'm so
excited to find out yeah i i you know it's not a
for sure thing like obviously it's not 100 certain
that's going to happen um i think we're leaning
that way but i guess to answer your previous
question of where is it going i think we have
to go after that store of value and secure that
kind of like reasoning on the base layer first
before we can easily obtain those other things
like easy day-to-day payments now i use lightning
network every day is it like the easiest thing in
the world well it's gotten a hell of a lot easier
since i first used it two years ago um you know
they you can auto swap in and out and it's still
cheap and fast but you know there's work to be
done obviously but i'm not as concerned about
having to jump through those hoops as long as the
the sanctity of that base layer value proposition
as sound money that is separate from the state
is maintained and all of those things that i just
talked about i think are entirely necessary to be
preserved in order to attain that okay so coming
towards the end of this um you can answer this one
quickly because then i want to talk about you and
what you're working on next um but i want to know
your opinion on which cryptocurrency you think is
going to take us mainstream so i think things are
going to go mainstream um you're probably going
to say bitcoin but i'm going to ask you anyway
um things are gonna go mainstream i hear 2023
is gonna be the year i hear that from a tech
perspective um i hear it from a fundamentals
perspective and then i also hear from like a
spiritual perspective you know i'm here in 2023
as a year um so which cryptocurrency is going
to do it um i mean doge is a bit of a meme um
things like link are doing some really things
like link uh coins the the coin link sounds kind
of weird when i say it link is doing some really
cool stuff so which crypto do you think will
take us mainstream and what are your thoughts
i mean you called my answer yes bitcoin um again
i'm not i'm not super convinced by anything else
given the the criteria that i laid out so like
okay let's let's take link for instance um
you know a lot of that has to do with pulling
off chain data pulling uh data in the real
world from oracle's and putting that onto
the blockchain so with that it you know
you can't get past the fact that data bad data can
in some circumstances be put onto the blockchain
it's it's possible to have bad data input
when you're taking it from a real world source
and so if that actually gets onto a blockchain
then some of that data on the blockchain which
is meant to be kind of a beacon of truth becomes
incorrect if you can go back and amend that data
and correct it then why are you using a blockchain
in the first place so i i've always kind of gotten
i've never been sold on on kind of this real world
off chain data on chain as as a use case because
and the supply chain stuff because the
inputs can potentially be bad and if you
can fix those inputs to make them correct then
a blockchain is completely useless to you so
but just on that point though i mean i wouldn't
say entirely useless because you know they're
using things like smart contracts and
decentralized exchanges and all these
sorts of things that we need blockchain for but
i understand how the information can be incorrect
but what if they're able to get to a point
whereby they make sure that it's not incorrect
well i mean how do you do that so like i i
know that there's there's mechanisms to to
um you know with link the they'll be and with
other chains there'll be mechanisms to try to
penalize people that do do things maliciously um
what happens in instances of like civil attack
where the vast majority of people agree to collude
together to do do things that are not necessarily
true you know like there's attack vectors that can
be had there um i just i haven't been convinced
with off chain data being used on chain i think
the reason that something like bitcoin works
is because it's purely digital it's a native
digital asset and so you don't need to audit
what's in the real world in order to know that
what's in front of you is true um so yeah like i
again i'll i'll listen to different things
when people pitch it but i haven't heard
very different pitches as of yet and so i'm
kind of i don't know i i'll i'll say that
my skepticism is is thought through i'm always
open to hearing other things but to date
when i list off the criteria where i think that
something is valid i just haven't seen that
opposing argument yet yeah no i i get that i think
i mean i'm definitely bitcoin for me is definitely
number one i definitely do see the i do see um
blockchain technology being used um outside of
sort of the bitcoin landscape um i'm definitely
someone who sort of sees the use case of it and
in countries that don't have the kind of financial
infrastructure that we have in terms of you know
getting mortgages and loans and things like that
you know like i get i get the d5 craze i get it um
but it's still super new it's super experimental
you know i'm with you in terms of it hasn't proven
itself entirely because like you said there
are still holes um in sort of making sure
that the blockchain is doing what the blockchain
is supposed to do immutable accurate transparent
and so on um so i'm with you i'm yet i'm yet to
see so just finally this has been a fantastic
chat um but finally what are you up to and also
where can people find you so just promote yourself
yeah uh so i mean i've been doing uh tutorials on
my youtube channel since 2016 now so it's going on
five years um so i do multiple videos a week
whether it be tutorials or one-on-one interviews
or panel shows so i always do those um you can
find me just searching btc sessions on youtube
you can find me on twitter at btc sessions
and uh you can find my website btc sessions.ca
that canadian uh canadian uh suffix there so
yeah um you can find me all over the place and
yeah i'm just doing my thing i'm i'm making shows
and enjoying being around and doing what i love
well i want to thank you so much for coming on
um you're an absolutely fantastic guest you're
so eloquent um you explained
everything beautifully
um and i i think it's so important to break down
these complex topics because for some people
um you know we hear double spend and you know
people think oh yeah yeah i get it but a lot
of people don't um especially what's going
on with gamestop and robin hood and why that
matters to our community so thank you so much
for coming on thank you for having me and guys
thank you so much for watching and thank you to
my sponsors we will see you next thursday bye